I think a lot of women are challenged
with many many things going on in their
life right you know whatever the work is
that they do being a spouse being a mom
they've got a lot of things going on
their life and it's harder to have that
one clear focus so one of the things we
have to do is inspire them convince them
it's really important it can improve the
quality of life for you and your family
and your neighbors and your relatives so
you should try to have that kind of
focus but I think it's a tougher
decision for women and men because women
tend to have more things going on I hope
the future of politics for women gets to
a place pretty soon or we don't ask
these questions anymore right you want
it to be irrelevant and I think it can
be the numbers are better they're much
better than they were even 20 years ago
Barbara Mikulski retiring recently
talked about it's never enough right but
again I think if we can inspire them and
demonstrate the value of it then we'll
get more of them in there
highly dependent on getting the best and
brightest young people involved alright
highly dependent on getting really good
people involved because we don't then
the only people engaged and active or
those who have nothing better to do but
I think we have a real responsibility to
inspire them right about the nobility
and the purpose and the relevance of
public service we have to enable them we
have to give them the tools they need
leading isn't as easy as it used to be
right there's a complexity now that has
to be addressed you have to give people
the tools they need to tackle those and
then we have to empower them right so
we've inspired them we enable them with
the right tools and then we have to
empower them and let them go and make
the meaningful changes that we have to
make to drive this this country through
the next century do it
I know it's hard I know it's scary I
know there are other paths that are easy
but do it again because I I desperately
care about the future of this country
and I want bright young people involved
and engaged I also know from personal
experience you'll have none as good
right you're part of something bigger
than yourself right whether you're on
Capitol Hill or working on a campaign or
working in a federal agency you're part
of something bigger than yourself and
that's a wonderful experience to have
you will learn things you will have
responsibility a young age that you
won't get anywhere else
so do it please
you